I assume you saw a triumph of the will?
I think I mentioned other day Leni Riefenstahl only died about four years ago,
uh,
at age 102.
And she did interviews.
Uh,
I,
and just look back on that regime is that she was a professional and,
uh,
she did,
she did a good job in her,
her employers in this case out off Hitler were pleased with their work.
Uh,
what's interesting about the film,
among the many things,
and some of the themes I'll touch on and you're reading about I,
is that,
I mean,
it's,
it's a combination of,
of the kind of medieval and they're very modern.
I mean,
Hitler,
Mussolini used use modern technology,
uh,
Germans who could barely afford to eat,
had radios and listened to the speeches of the funeral.
And it was the same thing in,
in,
uh,
in Italy with Mussolini.
Uh,
and a while you saw the images of,
of kind of a medieval and Nuremberg,
which was of course no longer exists,
medieval Nuremberg or not much of it.
Uh,
and,
and the kind of modern,
uh,
modern technology of the whole thing.
I mean,
Hitler,
Hitler liked airplanes.
He liked to fly around and,
and,
and for all of the kinds of images of the,
of the German warriors,
kind of a medieval,
medieval person who dies diving in a frozen Pomeranian ponds and things like
that,
uh,
you know,
with the terrifying we modern is of course apparent too.
And,
and,
uh,
and if you want it,
the most chilling example of the modern,
of course it would be the,
the assembly line,
the transformation of the assembly line,
uh,
into,
into mass murder,
uh,
the assembly line.
Um,
uh,
um,
in the,
in the death camps if you've been anyone here,
but nostra it's been to us with a deductible also a long,
long time ago.
But to Auschwitz,
I fairly recently,
one of the most chilling things about Auschwitz actually.
I mean,
the,
it just,
it's just beyond anything,
but it's the commandant's house because the commandant's house has little swings
out behind it.
And that's where the commandant lived.
And his wife said this was the happiest time of their lives.
And so the little children were playing in them in the garden.
Uh,
on the swings a and there's a big wall there,
but not a huge wall.
And the crematoriums are on the other side in that part.
That said,
I'll Schmidt's not in Birkenau,
which was a couple of kilometers away.
And that life went on in that way as this sort of assembly line.
Uh,
uh,
mass mass murderers of millions and millions of,
of people.
Uh,
they're a Hungarian Jews,
outnumbered.
Um,
a Polish shoes exterminated.
Auschwitz just barely.
That's because at the end of the war,
the Hungarians were,
were sending just huge trainloads of people to,
to be exterminated there.
Anyway.
Um,
so,
uh,
I want today to talk about off Hitler and I will bring in to this,
you know,
that some of the themes that you're about,
uh,
um,
but just two things at the beginning,
obviously national socialism was one variant,
uh,
certainly the most horrible variant of,
of fascism.
And you can put a Franco into that mix,
but they're,
it's authoritarian,
right wing authoritarian rule.
Um,
and that,
that,
uh,
as you know,
it was everywhere.
And secondly,
uh,
that like world war one,
I mean,
there's no other period of history,
this great literature,
at least in English,
uh,
about it.
And,
and they're a wonderful trilogy by,
uh,
Richard Evans,
um,
Hitler and the Nazis to 1933.
Then second volume was 1933 to the war two.
It's September 1st 39 and the third is 39 to,
um,
uh,
to the end,
to the bunker.
Um,
and also,
uh,
there are many biographies of,
of Hitler.
I read,
uh,
about three of them,
but the best by far is,
uh,
Ian Kershaw's,
two volumes very long.
But,
uh,
and I'll be drawing on that in part.
So,
um,
let's get going,
uh,
on that.
Um,
there's a,
there's a picture,
there's a photo.
It's not in the book.
Um,
but there's a photo of Hitler reviewing his,
his guys.
Um,
and that particular photo,
which was taken about 1927,
it was,
it was not from Amazon,
a huge field.
And you,
so you see Hitler reviewing his guys there.
Uh,
but what people don't realize is that picture was taken from a huge,
you know,
there's lots of other people out there,
a little groups like the Nazis might deliver than the law earlier.
And they,
uh,
they too have their leader,
their fear,
her and Hitler ends up the National Socialists ends up end up,
you know,
ended up winning,
but they weren't the only group.
Uh,
and you know,
I'm not a believer in the great person,
quote unquote,
uh,
in,
in history.
I mean,
Hitler did not make the Nazis a world war one created the Nazis.
A lot of the racism,
a lot of the,
this,
the idea of hygienic,
pure racial,
pure for gay purification and all that.
I mean,
that was all out there as you know.
And,
and I've tried to make,
make clear,
uh,
but if it would've been a Hitler,
there been somebody else,
and in 1933,
when Hitler becomes chancellor,
when the other rights,
I,
when,
what,
there are many rights,
but when von Poppen says we've got them boxed in,
now we can use Hitler for our own,
uh,
our own,
goals.
Well,
how,
how incredibly,
uh,
I naive,
that was,
but,
uh,
the Nazis and must be seen in the context of World War One.
They must be really be seen in the context of the poisoning of the put political
atmosphere,
uh,
between,
between the wars,
um,
in night in 1876 all the ways as she called Guber.
Um,
I didn't write it on the board.
I sent this stuff around to today.
A lot of it would not,
she can,
Guber is not on it.
The list changed.
Name to alloys.
Uh,
Ottawa,
you'd say in French.
I don't know what you're saying.
Germany.
Hitler.
Um,
eh,
it was a peasant family and lower Australia.
I all over Australia,
lower Austria.
Whew.
A bordering on bullying.
I been to Laura Australia.
I've been the Lord roster too.
But anyway,
bordering on a,
on a Bohemia,
thus his,
his,
the families dislike of checks and Hitler's particular dislike of checks.
But he just liked everybody,
uh,
outside of Germans.
Um,
his father was,
was it legitimate in quotes.
Um,
uh,
and ended up with the name of his mother's long,
deceased wife's father,
uh,
York Hadler,
a Hie,
d,
l,
e,
R,
which in 1876 became Hitler.
As I said,
there was a rumor even during the 1920s,
that,
uh,
Hitler,
his grandfather was Jewish.
And this,
these rumors circulated in Munich in the 1920s.
Hiller was born in [inaudible] on the border of Germany.
That is the,
the Austrian German border.
Uh,
and this was,
uh,
this was important and his obsession with,
with,
uh,
with uniting the two countries.
Um,
his father was a customs official,
uh,
comfortable kind of lower class,
existence,
but it was not a happy family and it was a at all.
His father was strict,
pompous,
proud of his,
his,
uh,
minimal status,
extremely pedantic and,
and,
and had a violent temper.
Uh,
he took care of bees with more loving attention that he took care of his family.
Um,
he managed the family,
uh,
with efficiency,
but without love,
a Hitler's mother as described by in Kershaw as a simple,
modest,
kindly woman,
uh,
who went to church.
And was devoted to her two surviving children odd off.
And Paula,
she smothered them with protectiveness out of Hitler,
feared,
but did not love his father.
But this,
uh,
you know,
does not explain the murderers result of the whole thing.
Civil servants get moved around a customs people,
and he moved to a,
the family moved to Linz,
L I N Z in Austria,
which was a hotbed of antisemitism.
Uh,
in 1895,
hiller began his schooling at age six,
uh,
he viewed a lens as his hometown,
and in that terribly too,
and to happy early life.
Uh,
uh,
look back,
almost installed your clay upon living in,
in Lens,
but he did not pick up his antisemitism.
Inlands uh,
he started a secretary schooling in 1900,
but he was unsatisfactory and mass and in natural history,
uh,
he didn't like his teachers.
Uh,
he,
um,
was,
uh,
in principle,
respectful,
but,
but he thought himself above many of them.
Um,
his,
uh,
he was badly adjusted.
His father wanted him to be a civil servant.
He wanted him to follow and be,
you know,
the next in line of the Hitler civil servants.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I'd also,
as you know,
resisted,
he wanted to be an artist.
Uh,
and his father said,
you will not be an artist as long as I am living.
Um,
Lynn's was,
uh,
besides being a hotbed of antisemitism,
it was a hotbed of German nationalism and not just Austrian German speaking,
nationalism,
but German in general.
Nationalism.
Um,
his father died in 1903,
and then I,
Hitler,
I hit the academic skids.
He failed in math.
Uh,
he moved to another school,
50.
You're a 50 miles away in a place called [inaudible],
but it wasn't any better.
Um,
and then he took up this sort of low idle existence.
Uh,
uh,
and he painted,
he read poetry.
Uh,
he attended the theater.
That's was one of his great loves.
Um,
in Lynn's a a 1905,
1907,
he had one friend or goosed,
Quba Sec,
uh,
who was the center of a POLST upholsterer.
And Hitler dominated them.
He needed somebody to listen to him.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
Cuba Sec,
was exposed and I suppose willingly to Hitler's diatribes is pontification his
monologues about virtually everything.
He was the classic kind of know at all.
He was Pale a sin.
Uh,
um,
he had that,
that little mustache,
uh,
that would become bigger.
He wore a black coat and a dark hat and he carried a black cane with a
pretentious ivory ivory handle.
Uh,
his great passion with Wagner,
um,
uh,
who goes to,
we know about music.
No,
the Wagner was a,
it was a rating anti-semite,
um,
and um,
as well in art as art and architecture,
uh,
about what she claimed to know a great deal.
He wanted to begin as artistic career at the academy in Vienna.
Um,
and his mother had fallen ill with cancer.
uh,
and soon died.
She died in 1907.
This struck him is a bolt out of the blue.
He remembered he applied for the academy and Giana and to his horror,
he was turned down.
He went to Vienna.
Anyway,
in February,
1908,
hoping to become an architect.
Uh,
he said later,
I owe it to that period that I grew hardened.
Uh,
he lived in Vienna from 1908,
February until May,
1913 he said later after the war,
uh,
during this political,
a sense that it was during that period,
that quote,
my eyes were opened to the two minuses of which I had previously scarcely known
the word,
uh,
the names,
Marxism and jewelry,
the Jews,
he,
Eh,
and this appears in mind comp.
I,
his,
my struggle,
uh,
which he wrote,
you know,
when he was in London's prison,
I even visited the cell once,
uh,
after the,
the old faded Beer Hall Pooch,
uh,
in,
in Munich in 19,
uh,
23.
Uh,
but this was out of,
uh,
out of retrospect,
there was really no evidence that he had become a raging a anti-semite before
1914.
Yet,
I mean,
antisemitism was,
was,
was so prevalent in Australia.
And Carl Lugar,
who was the,
uh,
you know,
when the mayor of,
of,
um,
uh,
of Vienna and whom I mentioned before,
was,
uh,
one of the worst in that period.
And,
and,
and he,
uh,
given this chilling quote before,
but I'll say it again.
He's the one said,
I decide who is a Jew.
Uh,
and,
and the liberalism that had been Vienna in the earlier period was a hardened,
like Hitler became hardened,
uh,
in to,
um,
uh,
just a vast,
a vast,
uh,
in,
in tolerance.
But at the time he said that,
that,
that these two menaces,
uh,
we're known to him,
he was struggling,
uh,
he wanted to be,
to be the man,
uh,
you know,
in leadership of the German,
right.
And so he was in sang this a,
if you believe Kershaw and I do on this,
uh,
and I'm much more,
that this was a fabrication are that the Anti Marxists,
the Anti Socialist and subsequent anticommunist after 1917 that was there and
his long diatribes in the serve shabby rooming house where they would sit
around.
And finally,
you can imagine one by one people just getting tired of listening to od off and
going up to their miserable little rooms to get some sleep.
We're against the socialist and the,
the,
the Austrian socialists like the German SPD,
uh,
counterparts had long marches,
through the streets of Vienna on behalf of workers rights.
Uh,
it's Cetera,
et cetera.
And,
and Hitler would stand on the porch of this room,
a house,
and simply hate,
hate them as a,
they went,
uh,
went,
went back,
but went by.
Um,
but yet,
I mean,
Vianna was a huge melting pot of this,
this enormous empire.
There are all sorts of people besides German speakers who lived in Vienna,
and many of the German speakers,
uh,
were Jews,
Freud among them.
I've,
I've been to Freud's,
uh,
almost bizarrely recreated,
um,
uh,
office there in Vienna,
but it had a,
a Jewish population was about 2% of the population in 1910.
It was 175,000 people in Vienna or,
but then it grew to 8.6%,
uh,
of,
of the population.
And later I went in and Hitler speeches,
thundering speeches over the top speeches.
Uh,
he,
um,
saw them as,
as,
uh,
as Jews,
as,
as capitalists exploiters of,
of,
of true Germans,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
but this,
this,
this came,
uh,
came,
later,
um,
Luger by the way,
anticipated Hitler and lots of other people by saying in,
in 1890,
the quotes that the Jewish problem,
quote unquote,
would be solved if all the Jews were placed on a large ship and sunk at sea.
But when,
when Paula went,
when out of Hitler lived with Cuba,
sac in,
in this rooming house and went to the theater,
uh,
with him,
he was not yet thinking of politics.
What he wanted to do was become this famous artist.
And then he,
it is true that he painted postcards for tourists,
uh,
which he sold to kind of keep himself,
float.
Um,
Kubitschek was a,
was a piano player.
So the room there was two bads and a piano,
and that was about it.
And so sometimes you can imagine the Kubitschek playing the piano just to try to
tune out,
odd off.
But he was rather low,
loyal to him.
A Hitler began to,
to write a play.
We went to the theaters,
I said,
and he got a little bit of inherited money after his parents died.
He had little interest in women.
And of course,
one of this are prevalent rumors,
is that,
that he was impotent,
uh,
though,
hit,
as you all know,
surely he would marry Eva Brown,
uh,
in the,
in the bunker,
uh,
before they,
took cyanide pills and killed themselves as the Russian tanks.
Could almost be heard rumbling above.
Um,
Eh,
we,
we no have no sexual experience,
um,
that he had,
uh,
he described the ideal woman that quote as a cute,
cuddly,
naive little thing,
tender,
sweet and stupid.
Uh,
and of course,
uh,
like Moose,
Moose Salini,
who was a,
you know,
notorious a philanderer,
and he used to brag,
uh,
tirelessly about his sexual exploits.
Uh,
both Hitler and Mussolini believed that women,
uh,
as place was in the home,
turning out a baby boy soldiers,
uh,
and,
and not in the factories.
And of course,
when the ironies is during the Second World War,
that,
that women are increasingly doing jobs that Hitler and Mussolini,
I thought were inappropriate,
uh,
simply because the men were,
were dead.
Uh,
but,
um,
anyway,
so he was prudish,
um,
seemingly repelled by sex,
although fascinated a Avaya.
Um,
and one of the points that Kershaw makes is that qubit checks,
uh,
recollections along with that of,
of,
of Hitler's a a sister Paula,
uh,
give us a sense of,
of some of the things that would remain characteristic of Hitler until his must
deserved end.
Uh,
basically,
uh,
he was lazy,
um,
that,
uh,
he was manic at times.
There'd be these bursts of wild enthusiasm for something he would,
uh,
during the war,
he would,
he would demand that the general's place maps in front of him and he would make
the decisions,
uh,
as the general secretly moaned about,
he consider himself an expert in military affairs as well.
Uh,
there was,
uh,
a pathological sense of reality and,
and,
and a sense of proportion,
ah,
and a vindictiveness that,
that,
uh,
as most of you that followed this at all,
I would know,
kept the Russian invasion,
stalled it as he punished the Yugoslavs,
uh,
poor troops in Yugoslavia to slaughter people.
And then,
uh,
I delayed the,
the famous,
uh,
invasion of the Soviet Union in,
in,
uh,
June 22nd,
was 21st I was in Kiev wants and the bells were all ringing.
And I realized that was the same time that the German planes had had first,
uh,
first arrived.
Um,
uh,
but you know,
he is intolerance.
His,
his flashes of anger,
his tediousness,
uh,
his sense of predestined greatness.
It was all there in the shabby little room rooming house.
Um,
and,
uh,
the sense of frustration,
that,
uh,
um,
that his genius wasn't recognized as genius,
wasn't recognized,
but,
but there is no evidence of tirades against Jews,
uh,
that would,
come,
uh,
come later.
Um,
a friend,
another friend of his,
a guy called the hunnish,
um,
about whom,
whom I know nothing,
um,
said that,
uh,
this was after Kubitschek had disappeared from Vienna in those days.
Hitler was by no means a Jew hater.
He became one afterwards.
I,
and in the words of Kershaw,
the first war,
one world war made a made Hitler possible.
And in 1920 he said,
for the first time in print,
Jews are to be exterminated.
And this is after the foundation of the German Workers Party in early in 18,
19.
And of course,
it's that party that that would become,
uh,
that that would become the Nazis.
Now there is a picture that may be doctored,
uh,
and that I apparently is no longer in the second edition.
It should be.
It was in the first edition of the war starting in,
in,
in Munich.
And I think I haven't mentioned this before,
and it's a crowd scene and people are,
are,
uh,
I mean the board has been announced the worst,
not in Munich,
but all these people are,
are around the hotel,
do the town hall.
And they're,
uh,
just exuberant.
He didn't see the smiling Hitler beaming,
happy,
fulfilled,
you know,
he's going to fight for fight for German nationalism.
Um,
and he did fight in the war.
He was one of the guys.
Um,
he would,
he was a,
a comrade because he,
he was wounded twice.
He was a runner in the war.
He carried messages,
uh,
from,
from officers,
uh,
to,
to the trenches.
And then he literally ran,
but you know,
kind of carried them,
but they called him a runners.
Um,
and so after the war,
he emerges as,
as the,
as do troops,
uh,
demobilized,
in country facing the challenges of,
of an uncertain future.
And,
and nowhere was that a future,
arguably more uncertain than,
uh,
in,
in Germany.
Um,
now,
not all veterans of the fight in the German war cause and World War One,
of course,
turn too far right?
Policy Politics,
uh,
the,
the s pay day,
the socialist veteran's organization was the largest of the mall,
um,
yet,
uh,
there are just an enormous continuity's between those German soldiers who
returned from the war,
uh,
with their weapons,
in their houses.
Uh,
joining the free core,
the fry core.
Uh,
they kept on marching,
they kept on training in their basements,
uh,
and they would,
come back and therefore be exposed to all of these currents.
The sense of betrayal,
again,
as I've said before,
this is the third time.
But how do you explain to the folks back home that you've lost the war when your
tubes are way inside of France,
they're not perched on the frontier.
There are way inside.
So it's got to be somebody's fault.
So whose fault is it?
It's the Jews and it's the socialists.
Um,
and it's the Weimar republic.
And so these themes come together and that's a constant theme.
Hitler,
Hitler believed.
If you told people the same lies over and over and over again,
that,
that they will believe them.
It was happens in our country too,
but in,
in Hitler's case,
the lies were even more a pernicious.
And so the revisionism becomes,
you know,
an official policy of all of these right wing groups of all of them.
But the thing that's really just incredible is that the people have memories of
Hitler.
And when you see pictures of them,
this kind of pulling the teeth,
I guess you'd say in French,
you know,
a sad sack,
uh,
you know,
wearing ill fitting clothes and,
and,
uh,
did not have friends.
Kubitschek had disappeared.
I had no idea where he,
uh,
what happened to him.
Um,
and who had big hope from self that could never possibly fulfilled.
And the idea of this,
those of you who have a partied in Munich,
you know,
on the tour or something like that,
and I partied in Munich,
but 20 years old,
we went to these places and,
and uh,
uh,
but,
but you remember when you go into these big places like the Hofbrau House,
which is one of the worst and these other places,
uh,
it is hard to imagine.
I mean,
this is where the right wing groups map that all of a sudden this,
this is kind of sad sack guy could jump or be lifted on a table.
He wasn't terribly athletic and suddenly have people listening to every word
that he said for hours,
for hours.
And those speeches,
have you ever heard,
you know,
his speeches,
if you're German is really good and mine is terrible,
I'd barely exists.
Uh,
if people would listen on the radio and he would build up with this,
just this,
this crescendo denouncing the will to power my struggle,
our struggle,
the German people struggle.
Those who have destroyed us,
those who signed on the dotted line,
the war guilt clause that said that Germany started at all,
we will get them back.
He says in 1925 when my mind conference published in 25,
we think is 25,
he says,
we will kill the Jews.
He says,
we'll expand elbow room living space that we will expand to the east.
He says this,
you could buy copies of,
of mine confident in,
in Manhattan.
You could buy,
you buy copies of it in,
in,
in a Melbourne.
You could buy copies of it anywhere was transfer,
translate in,
in a variety of languages.
And it was all there from the beginning.
And the consistency in what Hitler was telling,
uh,
was there all the way through.
It was there all the way through the concrete plans for the extermination of the
Jews as well as the Gypsies and of gay people as well.
Uh,
this,
these concrete plans will,
uh,
come later.
Doc.
How,
uh,
in 1933 was built with him in charge primarily to put communists,
in the house.
And then later,
uh,
of Jews,
many Jews were communists.
Uh,
and later,
you know,
other people.
And I went to doc how when I was your age.
And,
uh,
I remember seeing an old guy,
um,
working in the fields right outside the wall.
And he was old enough that that guy owned that farm back in nights from during
the war.
And people knew,
I'll come back to that in a minute.
They knew when you try to think,
what does he think when he saw the people come in?
What did he think when the smoke rose?
Uh,
what did he think they knew?
They knew and they didn't care.
Plan.
Now,
if Hitler's themes barely changed,
uh,
it raises some very important questions.
Who First supported Hitler?
Hitler support,
and I do write about this a little bit,
that the,
the role of the economic crisis cannot be underestimated.
The inflation statistics,
you will not want to commit those to memory.
But Art,
those are unbelievable.
The only case I know that that's vaguely like that.
Of course,
the Zimbabwe,
uh,
in,
in the [inaudible],
uh,
a period.
But this is even worse.
Uh,
if that is possible.
And middle class people who had to pawn our,
and why,
you know,
chess drawers,
silver that had been in their family for years in order had enough to eat,
they wouldn't forget.
And they blamed and they hate it.
It's the fault of the allies.
It's the fault of the Jews.
It's the fault of the socialist.
It's a fault of the communists.
It's a fault of Weimar.
And they first flocked to Hitler.
The middleclass has to now,
if this sounds like an Orthodox Marxist interpretation,
that's what the Marxist Orthodox say.
And they're right
now,
big business did not flock to Hitler.
Big Business wanted the destruction of Weimar.
They help make Hitler possible.
Only one big businessmen gave Hitler a lot of money.
He got a lot of small donations,
but pretty soon he gets started,
introduced to the right people,
the right cocktail party.
They thought he was vulgar.
Quick Story.
I had a colleague died decades ago,
was very nice to me when I came here was a German,
uh,
diplomatic,
his story.
And Cole Haans got ski and he left.
He wasn't Jewish and he wasn't a communist,
that's for sure.
Uh,
and he left Germany in the,
in the,
in the third,
mid thirties,
because he didn't like what was going on.
He didn't like what's going on.
And he got a job translating for the Canadian Olympic team.
And I said to him once,
did you ever see Hitler?
And he said yes.
And he was under the stadium in Berlin.
And like any big stadium,
you know,
you've got,
you've got space underneath a lot of places they have,
you don't batting cages some times was a baseball stadium or something like
that,
but he was down there,
were supposed to meet the Kitty and Olympic team.
And all of a sudden you heard this enormous roar machinery as you know,
machine gun carrying,
uh,
vehicles are coming in.
And by incredible coincidence,
he had a couple of pillars here.
And just about where Leslie is,
there was odd off Hitler.
It was odd.
Off Hillary.
He was scared because her machine is all,
he stood there frozen and he wasn't,
you know what?
They've got them down.
No.
Well,
he just standing there and I said,
what?
What did you think?
What did you think your fifth,
15 yards away from odd off Hitler,
less than that.
And he said,
I had a weird reaction.
He was vulgar.
He was the Austrian corporal.
He sneezed and he blew with nose on his sleep.
That's what God's key remember now,
big business,
uh,
[inaudible] was a moderate,
you know,
political,
uh,
you know,
he was not at all,
I mean,
not all,
not,
but uh,
but he,
and he also did,
he would believed in the Weimar republic.
He was a very good guy.
Rick Aristocratic Guy.
He was over Ryan Lender.
He,
uh,
but his reaction was the same as big business,
except that they want big business wanting to destroy Weimar.
But the reaction with a Hitler as a commoner,
he's vulgar.
He's,
uh,
we've got them locked in.
They said in 1933,
we've got a boxed in and we can use them to our advantage.
And then have a Miller Charlie dictatorship when von Stauffenberg tries to kill
Hitler and puts a under the table and it blows up but doesn't kill Hitler
because of big old German wooden barrier.
It was the table,
uh,
stood on,
you know,
he wasn't trying to bring parliamentary regime back to Germany.
He wanted to know literary dictatorship.
Um,
but,
but he,
you know,
he would,
Hitler was supported by the,
by,
uh,
the middle classes disproportionately at,
at,
at the beginning,
but by all classes,
uh,
people supported him.
Workers less so,
but they break in 1933 to destroy the unions.
They destroy the Communist Party.
They used the right stock fire,
which is actually set by the guy probably now we think the Dutch guy,
who am I right about in there,
they destroy the unions.
They destroy the possibility of resistance.
But lots of workers where their sig io too,
but less so than the other classes.
What about religion?
Hitler?
Hitler was a southerner.
He never liked Berlin and all he wanted to raise it or in order,
and then then build this sort of,
you know,
Art Deco,
a monument of his,
his own planning.
But he was,
you know,
he was a,
he was a southern guy,
but one of the places he first does very well Schleswig-holstein,
which we've part of it,
when it used to be Danish and it's totally Protestant.
Um,
the Catholic Church rings the bell and reads what Hitler wants to read from the
sermons.
They're happy to have a,
uh,
have Hitler there,
as are the,
um,
you know,
as,
as are the Protestants there.
There's,
uh,
um,
it,
no doubt about that,
but the,
these kinds of,
you know,
the,
the fascism is in the air all over the place and the kinds of,
the main elements of fascism that I list,
if you sit in that book,
if you think about them,
they all apply to Hitler,
into the people who followed him.
Anticommunist antisocial,
a Socialist,
Antivia Amar,
uh,
the role of the economic crisis with long,
long memories and hating the allies and hating the Jews.
And hating the Socialists,
uh,
violence that,
you know,
the Nazis were at other fascist groups are better at saying whom they were
against than what they wanted.
A lot of say what they want is ultra nationalism,
but they want us to,
to tell him interior Tyrian state and the destruction of parliamentary rule.
What they want is a dictator.
Uh,
they want to cut deal as,
as Franco was.
They want to do che as,
as,
as a Mussolini.
He called himself,
they want a few of her or they want a leader who incarnates in that mystical
body as they would view it.
The aspirations of the German people
and part of what whom you were is who you are excluding.
You have a volkist community in the perverse,
biological racism of,
of these people and other people who aren't in it.
Too Bad for them.
If they are work shy Germans who don't want to work,
then they're not really part of the,
of,
of the,
uh,
of volkist community.
I decide who's a Jew and who isn't.
That's what Lucas said.
Hitler says,
and this is the horror it all.
We decide who will live and who will die and when they're using euthanasia as a
tool to,
to kill people who are mentally handicapped.
And even some people who are physically handicapped.
And Pretty soon in the late thirties,
the Germans say,
wait,
these are Germans,
you know,
if there are Jews whom,
and I'm German,
but we don't get service of German,
that's okay.
Get rid of them.
So they pull back on that.
But it's,
that's there from the beginning,
ultra nationalistic,
ultra Antia a parliamentarian as you want the guy,
he's going to represent you.
What he's going to tell you what to do.
But they did.
And at the terror is there.
I mean,
the violence is there,
the Gestapo,
uh,
you know,
people that there are hundreds of thousands of dumb creation.
If you did announce somebody,
you can be sending them to torture and,
and their death.
There's no question about that.
And they're just annunciations all the time.
Hey,
my neighbor,
he,
I think he's Jewish.
Uh,
I know my neighbor down the hall,
I know he was a big guy in the s and the German Socialist Party.
SPD.
I know that,
that the butcher around the street,
you know,
I might want his store cause I'm a butcher too.
I know he was a communist activist until 1933 and you send it and annunciations
they got them all the time.
They got them all the time.
Here's a quote,
somebody describing one of the Gestapo offices and the bureaucratization of
terror and it's grimy.
I'm just a quote.
Grimy corridors officer's furnished with Spartan simplicity offices furnished
with Spartan.
Simplicity,
threats,
kicks troops chasing chain men up and down the reaches of the building,
shouting rows of girls and women's,
uh,
standing with their noses and toes against the wall.
Overflowing Ashtrays,
portraits of Hitler and his aides.
The smell of coffee.
Smartly dressed girls working in a high speed behind typewriters.
Girl,
seemingly indifferent to the squalor and agony about them.
Stacks of conference came to publications,
printing machines,
books and pictures and Gestapo agents asleep on the table.
Nobody had any illusion about what was going on and they didn't just rule
through terror.
You know,
the SS,
by the way,
everybody knows what the ss,
I mean they'd destroy the essay.
They,
Ernst Rohm Challenges Hitler and the night of the long life,
they wipe them all out.
The SS was a form of sort of social mobility for people.
These young guys come back after the war.
There was no work and pretty soon in the 20s,
they get it.
You Ss,
you've got a uniform,
you can go beat the hell out of out of a communist Jews or anyone else.
And there's no,
the judges are all a Nazi sympathizers,
a right wing sympathizers.
They were all trained in the empire.
Uh,
you can kill somebody and you'll be out of jail in,
in,
in a,
in a very short matter of time.
I mean,
you're,
you're working with impunity,
uh,
especially in Prussia where we're gerbils as administer of,
of the interior.
Um,
there's a goring is administer of interior in PR in Prussia.
I don't remember.
Anyway,
uh,
it is all routinize.
It,
it is all there,
but they don't rule just through terror.
And that's what I did not emphasize enough in what your,
um,
in,
in what you read and it's going to be in the next edition.
The Hitler promises order and order is zero tolerance on petty crime for
example.
Uh,
and they have police who are called the creepo appropriately enough in English
translation.
But uh,
uh,
K R I p o and they are so your basic police,
they're not thinking Estoppel but they go out and,
and,
and people who are lounging about who our work shy,
that's a dangerous thing to be work shy,
uh,
you know,
petty criminals,
people who are hungry,
who are,
who are stealing apples off of fruit stands,
things like that.
They go out and they make war on them.
Uh,
and the German population knots enthusiastically,
uh,
overall,
as a,
as a whole,
uh,
the war on crimes is something they like.
Now also there's the economy.
Now Hitler got credit for many German people,
uh,
for having revived the front,
the German economy.
How does he do that?
He does it by starting,
by violating the statutes of the treaty of Versailles.
And there,
there are preparing for war.
He's preparing for war all the way through.
If the Rheinland occupation,
the French and the Belgians had had,
had put up a fuss,
it's possible that the whole thing could have been stopped there quick as
possible.
The generals are,
are saying mind.
Sure her,
you know,
we're not really ready yet for war.
I,
while he is,
is a freezing,
freezing the,
uh,
his,
his opponents and they capitulate one time after another.
And the famous story of Neville Chamberlain had returned bringing peace in his
time after having sold out Czechoslovakia.
But the German economy does revive.
There's still huge gaps between obviously the wealthy and people who aren't
wealthy,
uh,
enormous gaps,
but the German economy and he takes credit desert vibe because of the same thing
that happens in the United States and World War Two,
because you're turning out transforming,
uh,
the war economy.
And that's exactly what happened.
So he takes credit for this and there are a lot of flashy gestures.
The VW,
I went around Europe in a VW with couple of my friends sleeping on beaches,
a little VW,
the Volkswagen.
But only one of them was ever produced.
He promises the German people at Volkswagen,
but only one model ever.
It comes off,
you know,
for the press and all that,
the Autobahn,
they're going to have roots,
Autobahn all over.
Now there are in Germany and people driving 500 miles an hour,
uh,
with impunity.
Uh,
there are only 500 kilometers or miles of a transfer in the,
in a miles of a autobahn done by the time he's finished strength through joy.
He announces a program that the Germans who have never been on vacation,
ordinary working class,
Germans can go on vacation.
Some people did go on vacation,
they all get drunk on,
on,
on cruise boats and,
and,
you know,
all over the place and,
and,
but hardly anyone gets to go.
But he gets credit for it then.
So he seemed to be producing,
he seen to producing and in a country in which antisemitism,
uh,
despite the fact that Jews were terribly assimilated,
ah,
we're a,
was endemic.
Uh,
they liked the fact that Jews are disappearing.
They like it and they know it.
And it's sure nonsense.
To think that people didn't know what was going on because as these trials are
put in the papers all the time,
so and so's been condemned being sent away to two.call because of anti state
behavior,
anti-German behavior,
you name it.
People know they have no doubts about it.
Where do I take the trains are going,
they can kind of imagine,
uh,
you know,
where are these people coming from?
What and when all the Polish workers are coming in,
being brought in as her slave labor,
slave labor,
the ones who haven't been destroyed,
uh,
when they're coming to work in the factories,
where do these people think their families were?
Well,
they're all dead.
Uh,
that's why ordinary men is such a chilling book because at how these people,
these,
you know,
this police officer brigade,
uh,
in Homburg how these people can put bullets in the,
in the backs of the heads of old ladies and little children in the,
in the killing fields of around wallets or anywhere else in Poland is just an
extraordinary story.
People knew.
Not everybody knew,
but they knew.
They knew.
Uh,
and,
and for people who wanted order,
this was their idea.
This was the racial idea of order.
The universities,
what happens to the universities?
Well,
certain fields do very well.
Racial hygiene.
They established established chairs and racial hygiene,
a German folklore,
they established chairs and German folklore.
Physics does very well for obvious reasons.
Physically equals equals rockets,
uh,
military history,
chairs and military history chairs in,
in,
in German history chairs and particularly in German,
medieval history.
But,
but anything else,
you know,
your basic history,
uh,
um,
German literature for example,
uh,
it doesn't do very well.
Uh,
there was a famous headline than I that isn't in the book,
uh,
saluting the fact that people were,
there were less visits to libraries and people were checking out books and far
fewer numbers than they did before.
Um,
how do they pull this off?
They pull it off through sort of the atomization of society.
Uh,
and that one of the ways that there's a really wonderful book called the Nazi
seizure of power,
uh,
written about a town near Hanover,
and he changes the name of the town.
But then people were so proud of that book in the 1960s,
in 1970s,
they put stacks.
I'm say,
that's us.
That's us who were beating up the Jews.
That's us who were beating up the communists.
We are so proud.
Uh,
it's a very good book,
William share down the Nazi seizure of power.
And there's another good book by Rudy Kosher or a friend of mine at Wisconsin
on,
on a Marburg and a ton of Marburg.
What they do is they get Nazis into every voluntary association basically,
uh,
and they take them over.
And so what you have is the atomization of society.
That what Ian Kershaw calls going to the fuel.
Her only thing left is the family.
You protect yourself in the family or you thrive in the family,
but you're the family and your,
your children are in a Hitler youth.
Uh,
you,
uh,
there is no possible organized wave opposition,
soccer clubs,
football clubs,
everything is,
is,
is a part of the atomization because it's been taken over by the Nazis.
There is almost no resistance in Germany.
I'll talk a little bit about this next time,
um,
because this was a regime as capable as they did and Dusseldorf of,
of hanging 16 year old boys,
uh,
because they listened to Benny Goodman or were considered to be slackers or work
shy.
There's the,
there's that phrase again.
So this autumn is,
this atomization,
uh,
of,
of German society makes all of this possible.
And the most,
you know,
when Staffan replaces his bomb and the thing,
thing blows up and it doesn't kill Hitler,
Hitler amuse himself and his friends by,
by all the people and all the families and people involved,
uh,
they film them being thrown slowly,
strangled with was wire and they laughed as they,
as they watch the film.
But the most amazing chilling thing,
even more than that,
it's the Germans pouring into the street in 30 or 40 different cities is bombs
had been raining down all the time.
And they think,
God,
my God,
you saved our fuel,
her.
Whoa,
that's extraordinarily difficult to explain.
And by 1944,
the armies are full of old men and boys,
you know,
cause everybody,
basically everybody else's dad and the,
and they keep fighting.
They fight until,
uh,
you know,
with astonishing and foolish courage,
uh,
until uh,
the bitter,
bitter end.
They believe not everybody believed.
Uh,
and there'll be a revival of,
but you know,
even in the German federal public was just replete with,
with,
uh,
you know,
former,
uh,
very proud former Nazis who take,
take,
you know,
hugely important positions and,
uh,
in power after that.
And of course,
the good old Americans,
uh,
you know,
help a lot of these,
a Nazi war criminals escape to Paraguay and places like that in exchange for
information about,
about,
you know,
communist movements and that sort of thing.
They believe they believe and they believe not everybody believed.
Uh,
but,
but that's one of the scariest things about the whole thing is that it was sig
heil until the end.
Again,
not for everybody,
but for some social classes and others.
It was a,
and you find this in other countries,
and I'll talk a little bit about that when I talk to him.
I guess I'll talk mostly about,
about France,
uh,
next time.
Um,
so,
um,
he,
you know,
Hitler Hitler gives them basically what the German people,
what they want and his prestige,
right?
Every time he stands down,
uh,
Britain,
the British and the French,
every time that he pulls this off,
uh,
the occupation of the Rheinland,
the absorption of the Sioux Dayton,
uh,
part of Bohemia,
and then they just take over the whole country,
the Anschluss where he's greeted enthusiastically by the crowd.
You can see these photos of the adoring Viennese crowds,
uh,
in a,
where was the Vienna of,
of,
uh,
of calm concerts.
It became the Vienna Wagner.
It became the,
uh,
the Vienna of,
of,
uh,
of saluting Hitler and then going out and beating up and killing Jews.
Something like a hundred user are murdered in,
in,
in Vienna.
When Hitler arrives to celebrate the arrival of I'd off Hiller.
Uh,
it's,
they too,
you know,
they,
they believed in one of the,
you know,
the dark secrets of course was a Nazi pass of the former secretary general of
the United Nations could Waldheim and that came out.
All this came out before,
you know,
before most of you are reading newspapers,
some of you are reading them,
uh,
back then because it was about what,
15 years ago or something like that.
Uh,
the people,
uh,
the people knew.
Um,
so those are the really the big points,
uh,
that I,
that I wanted to make.
And when,
um,
uh,
when you were reading a German women are German men sitting,
waiting to get their hair done.
When you read,
you read a popular newspaper,
which are popular magazine,
all of which had had articles about,
about Hitler and this sort of entourage and all that.
And you read,
uh,
you know,
a cheery headlines such as gas mask for children now readied,
uh,
you've sort of nodded incest yet,
yet we will be ready for,
uh,
the struggle because what happened was mine comp,
this struggle,
uh,
Hitler's book,
mind coffee became perceived of an adopted by the majority of people,
uh,
in Germany.
And they,
you know,
uh,
tragically enough,
they remain with,
um,
without off Hitler,
uh,
and,
and the Nazis until,
and told the,
uh,
the very,
very,
uh,
a bitter end.
And of course,
it's important to see the context is that in all of these places,
whether you're talking about Brussels,
whether you're talking about Amsterdam,
whether you're talking about,
uh,
we've heard about Prague,
any place you're talking about it in,
in Europe or Oswald Mosley strutting through Hyde Park with his,
his,
uh,
a little,
not sealing followers.
Uh,
Hitler was just the,
the,
the most violent,
uh,
the most egregious,
the most horrible,
the most tragic,
a example of what was the general,
uh,
phenomenon.
And throughout the entire period,
uh,
at different degrees of success,
during,
uh,
the twenties and thirties.
And so the war that began in 1949 and 1914 basically does not end,
uh,
until,
at least in Europe until the,
uh,
the defeat,
finally of,
uh,
of,
of Germany and the death of Idof.
Hitler is still at a relatively young age in the bunker in Berlin.